too close what was that what was that
like you're making it hard for me
oh yeah there he goes that song is so
vulgar
girl i know you felt it girl you know i
can't help it
[Music]
get your life together touch me bro i'm
not touching you dude
did you get a haircut uh
i don't know actually does it look like
it
it does it looks a little shorter up top
oh yeah it could be shorter
it looks structured mm-hmm oh really
yeah oh word man
you know beautifully designed yeah oh
that's like a piece of art oh damn i
like that yeah
you know most people can't do that with
their hair
[Laughter]
steal everything from your dog you know
what i'm saying i steal him bro he's i
know he is dude i'm going to be
trying to do it too i'm going to try to
do it i'm trying to do something you
know get that frederick douglass dog go
big
i agree what the [ __ ] is that even what
does that look like frederick douglass
long should i get it we close this door
chin close that door get some extensions
in that [ __ ] chappelle
dudes do get extensions yeah you could
get a wheel
man i feel like you're really and not to
judge you man oh yeah
i'm not taking no judgment but you're
taking but i am going to judge you but
it's also you coasting bro
yeah you coasted man dude this is a
regular hair too easy i'm just saying
well that's too easy no mix it up
well here's what i'm saying is to be
black and do what you're doing bro
yeah spice it up you should get some
bangs
dude you could do all kind of stuff you
could dress i mean like you could do
there's so many things you can do man
you could do dreadlocks you could do you
could do you know get a
uh ass curl get a um your father drawing
into the side of your head or something
that's what i'm talking about they do
that art doug
yeah get [ __ ] kobe shaved into your
head or something do some [ __ ]
24 right here yeah diet blonde like
whatever you've got thick wesley snipes
man sure he's been a bunch of stuff
though yeah who has
wesley pipes snipes was his knives and
he died i think wesley pipes no he's
alive
is he he went to jail yeah he didn't pay
taxes he didn't pay taxes he's got to
get away with it yeah
oh yeah oh yeah that happens man
having a western snipes irs doesn't [ __ ]
around
lauryn hill a lot of famous hammer a lot
of famous black people don't play taxes
and white people
yeah who's the most famous that didn't
pay taxes
nick cage i was just going to say
nicholas cage he got trouble for buying
like castles and [ __ ]
and a dinosaur skull god
he bought a triceratops yeah would you
get you a dinosaur skull
i'd get maybe something you know i get a
female or something i'm not picking up a
full skull
no i don't want the full things to take
up too much space i'll get like a
stegosaurus tail or something [ __ ] my
tail yeah you want the femur but i don't
know how much bone the tail has in it
oh a stegosaurus tail maybe we should
get one for the studio
wrap this [ __ ] up we're barely paying
people as it is dude we're not doing
that
that's fair
you want to add a stegosaurus keep
growing that fat mullet you [ __ ]
dog that's a stegosaurus snail right
there dude
wait what's that oh nick looks kind of
like nick cage nick looks like nick
caged
okay yeah uncaged uncaged
no he looks like david on letterman he
looks just like
david letterman he looks like rabies
letterman rabies
that's a bit much i really respect david
letterman but i feel like i should be
offended by that you told me that when
we were in nashville i look like a boy
really he's a legend bro yeah that's a
that's a he is
a legend you look that's your dad yeah
that's your i know you don't know who
your dad is that's your dad
and that's why we brought you here today
david letterman is your father
that's my that's why my grandma would
always curse when he came on late at
night she hated watching him
do they not look [ __ ] like crazy
does he have a gap too yeah yeah he
david letterman definitely does i do a
little bit i mean he looks spot-on yeah
what are we talking about
i don't know i mean well i mean put the
beard picture up of him why are you
gonna put him picture i mean it's
yeah get that one right there look i
mean he's dated some
busted women dude yeah
remember remember got in trouble because
he's like [ __ ] some of the people on
the show and then came out i was like
yeah i did it
it was it was like the best reveal of
all time he's like there's been rumors
i've been had
inappropriate relationships with people
on my staff into that i say
yes i had inappropriate relations with
people on my staff but then it was over
like there was no like he just hit it
head-on and then everyone's like
well there's that and he's like yeah
hold on yeah
we need some of that up in here man yeah
yeah yeah
who's the one to do it though there's
just too many dudes yeah you want a
promotion
yeah yeah i i didn't say that and i
don't condone that either
i'd like them to be a little more goal
motivated nobody
to be fair chappelle did look at theo
lovingly in the eyes and said that he
was a pretty crier
oh that was yeah i did say that dude i
wouldn't touch half these
in here but i do want to know this
cat who would you if you had to you know
move forward uh between everyone in the
room or
just my bosses if you had to move
forward by choice
okay some lucky yes man in the room
so any man in this room not necessarily
just my bosses
uh it's any man in this room okay and no
one is your boss right now
and no one has my body okay let me close
my eyes we're all equals
and also each man gets one it is going
to have 30 seconds to
at first plead their case as to why
they should be the one who gets to have
you
let's go let's do it and it's for wife
it's not
anything
[Laughter]
nothing you guys are going to play back
later and masturbate
[Laughter]
i can reach on my material man
and chin no insider trading either yeah
obviously on the great rules yeah okay
let's start off with
uh let's start with chappelle lacey let
me get a timer
60 seconds like that show uh what was
the show the blind date show everyone
oh yeah like behind the wall okay i'll
close my eyes okay
or maybe catch could ask like three
questions we answer them okay
oh no just like the show like what would
you do on our first date go through
uh i don't know i do like that we have
to explain ourselves
i was kind of like prepping my monologue
in the time since you said it
i would like to stick with the original
constraints get a monologue and then cat
gets to ask one question
maybe let's see how the monologues go
this could be a horrible idea yeah let's
play it by ear
okay we have 60 seconds nick you want to
run it yeah
uh run that [ __ ] uh should i join first
yeah
three two one go uh my name is chapelle
lacy
i'm 33 years old i'm an aquarius i'm a
great guy
i don't come with any extra baggage any
previous crazy relationship stuff
um i like to read a lot i like to
invest a lot of time into the
relationships that i'm in to
give my best i like to deliver my best
to everyone around me
44 no
because you get weird at six months at
30.
leave them alone 30 more seconds 30 more
seconds leave him alone
five more seconds five more seconds
uh five more seconds uh and
uh uh um great in bed
all right all right nick appropriately
time's up
yeah yes uh
okay that was a good joke thank you
thank you thank you yeah we slept online
cat can hear all of it then ask
questions okay oh then ask a question so
go me then yeah
all right your voice a little if you
don't want cat to know who it is
yeah you could do something like that
although we said the names already
okay somebody who somebody else can go
now okay i'm not going to say who i'm
going to count down and just go since we
decided already
three two one go
as long as you teach your kid if we have
a kid as long as you teach him how to
google
he'll be the utmost perfect child that
knows how to do everything
100 than most other people
he's also he's he's also an anomaly in
height
uh so if you had a kid with this person
uh you could be the tallest
asian i don't want the voice is making
it worse
all right it's a beautiful singer i
think it's already 30 seconds
obviously serial killer why that guy
needs alcohol
okay unbelievable shots
he's the only date rapist that doesn't
date that doesn't break
that's chin dude and that's a good thing
thank you and
that's a good thing but yeah i would
never i couldn't even imagine
it sounds like the lines got crossed and
somebody was just talking to somebody
oh okay
all right who's next a theo's next
mystery man number three someone is next
all right
three two one go
good afternoon um i would like to say my
name
is theo and that could be just a say a
fake name but um
i am for i'm from march i was born in
march
and the one thing you get with me is a
decent guy
so you get a guy that wakes up every
morning goes to bed every night
you know you don't get like a crazy guy
that's
you know uh selling drugs or anything
like that or uh
you know having a bunch of baby mamas
are listening
that's pretty good that was pretty good
what's that
am i up all right ready i'll go three
two one go
[Applause]
okay you ready you got it hey my name my
name is brendan
uh 37 years old
my friends would consider me thick
thicker
i ride my bike every day it's one of my
passions
i love animals i love animals one thing
about me i love to eat
i got sweet my friends would say i have
sweet teeth i'm a big foot
guy and uh i'm down for open
relationships
guys that's fine
okay last contestant here we go rides
bikes and then the black guys i mean
that guy sounds trouble he said you
sound homeless
yeah three i ride my bike every day
to one go
um hi i'm nick um in
in my dating history i've dated a
vietnamese girl so i
know i know how to treat uh your kind i
guess
yeah i i know i'm not the only one
that dated a vietnamese girl in here
but uh but the other guy was asian and i
know asian girls don't like other asians
they usually go for white guys uh
bringing the racial hate
look chinese are the black people of the
asian community i used to live in my car
and i don't anymore
so i've dated uh asian before and i
don't think you guys should be caged up
can i open my eyes yeah
i do have a question for the last guy
okay uh i just wanted to know where did
you
keep your girlfriend in a cage or a
kennel
[Applause]
i have one question for the first
gentleman uh who went he said that he's
good in bed at the very end by bed do
you mean taking naps
and are you a cuddler yeah define bed
yeah uh uh touch is my love language
so i am a great cuddler and uh
yeah i do take naps about 20 minutes
every day every day a little
power on the hour oh yeah oh yeah oh wow
on the hour oh god someone said lazy i
would never
20 minutes every day on the hour but
that's a stereotype dude okay
yeah right you hear what you said about
me theo get him it hurts my heart man
yeah
come on i will fill out another con and
i will i do have seven
uh alternate accounts that i youtube
comment on
and i will continue to use them with
human resources
which is just nick i'm relaxed
and most of the complaints are against
him because i've dealt with your kind
for me if you're like me
man i'm not you're not you're not you're
not as thick as me but i'll be eating
dinner and i'm thinking
i need something after this i need
something to wash this meal down with
i need another meal oh man i need
someone to deliver it
you're like somehow yeah i remember one
time he said hey pick me up one of those
wet
meals and i was like what do you mean
like a smoothie you're like yeah yeah
smoothie dog
but look man the thing is is that food
now you can't go outside somebody has a
disease somebody has aids somebody has
covered you got to be careful
so the thing you need to do is postmate
it man yes they'll bring it to you you
need it they'll bring it to you what do
they bring big dog what do you need
burger sushi
you need you need something at walgreens
7-eleven they do that man just download
the
post mates app all right find your
favorites and get anything you want
delivered within one
hour man burgers mutton anything man
and uh other things also you want a
frosting treat you want a sugar cookie
you want a slurpee
yeah you want it all baby or you want
none of it yeah they got chick-fil-a
they got that post-weights is giving you
guys 100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days that's for limited time only
what start your free deliveries download
the app and use the code kats2020
that's code kats2020 for 100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days when you download the
postmates app
anything you need anytime you need it
postmates that's right you can even get
on your mom's phone get the app
do it like that get the free hundred use
your sister's phone you got christmas
dinner man you know
tis that time of the year dog well where
you want to stay hydrated
yeah yeah oh yeah dude the thing about
you know
your body's mostly hydration yes if
somebody dehydrated you
you'd weigh probably six pounds i'd be a
nice beef jerky though
yeah sweet thick beef jerky yeah i mean
you probably
you definitely give somebody cavities i
bet that yeah that's for sure listen man
stay hydrated and dutch don't do it with
regular water
how about you use liquid iv all you do
is put in 16 ounces of water you get two
to three times the amount of hydration
as plain water
who drinks plain water not me i don't
dude i never i'll actu if it's bottled
but i'm not drinking out of the tap in a
bathroom i go straight tap to the dome
dog
damn really on an airplane yep
that's nasty dude drink it straight out
of that weird toilet it's so close to
that toilet bro it's disgusting
gross i was on a plane one time a guy
went in there with a uh
like a mix it yourself coffee cup and
went in there and got some water on the
bathroom and made it hell yeah
man but what i'm talking about a liquid
iv man and this they call it
one thing you don't know about it they
call it the hydration multiplier
so that's like somebody runs up and you
know hit you with a water balloon
but liquid iv comes up and hits you with
30 water balloons yes all up in your
mouth
listen they got delicious flavors how
about that sweet and juicy guava my
favorite crisp watermelon
they even got apple pie for you thick
boys out there man
yes it's healthier than some sugary
sports drink get that out of my face
five essential vitamins more vitamin c
than an orange what it's non-gmo it's
vegan
no gluten dairy soy and look here's the
thing
is that you can feel it when you drink a
liquid ivy
uh serving you could feel it oh
instantly man and liquid iv is available
nationwide at walmart
in the beverage section or you can get
25 off when you go to liquidive.com use
the code kats at checkout
yep that's uh promo code k-a-t-s
at check out liquidive.com get better
hydration today at liquidity.com promo
code cats
okay so going down the list i would say
the definite nose
is gonna be the what was it
the gentleman who said that he was also
asian
it kind of sounded like he was giving me
a description of
he is trying to like procreate not
necessarily be in a relationship like
out of duty and i'm looking for love
yeah i wasn't feeling him either i
noticed that
yeah i feel the same way so that's chan
and he's out
next one is the gentleman who rides
bikes he says that he likes black men
and i don't know i said it's okay if you
can't rebuttal brendan well don wherever
because she's confused i just say i like
oh okay that changes okay that's fine
you can rebuttal i'm open to what i said
oh okay i thought you said you liked
black men i was going to tell you i
didn't like the show everyone's in the
hot tub drinking and you know
got it chappelle's in there says love
language is touch
wait let's put a black guy in there
though
okay
i love how open that gentleman is but i
feel like i can't deal with a cuck
yep i've kind of dealt with that in the
past can't do it now
um let's see and
dude then cuck dudes uh tried it did not
work
so let's see jesus uh
there's the guy who says that he is into
my kind
he's dated my kind and i'm gonna super
racist
i'm gonna go ahead and say that's a hard
no by referring to
my people as your kind it's going to be
a hard pass
so it's going to be 20 nick yeah it's 20
20 brother stay woke
there was a man who said that he is a
decent man who wakes up in the morning
and night
i liked that he was the most normal out
of everybody but it did sound like he
was going in for a job interview yeah
your ticket your ticker's off
yep that's fair um i think
out of all of them i would have to go
with the first contestant who's working
on himself and touches a love language
wow that guy yeah you were a close
second i will say
look at you guys if you gave a little
more like
i'm looking for love i would have given
in i'll take a second because i don't
know if i was definitely down for it but
i wouldn't
make a choice for you but if something
happens to the first guy then i would
definitely i would step up and i would
be the man you need me to be
yeah like if the first day didn't go
well i'd hit you up like
on the way home and that would be right
there second place is what you want now
you can be the bachelor
yeah yeah you're that shoulder to cry on
yeah you know what i'm saying
well when i [ __ ] up that's a little too
much responsibility yeah
okay nevermind just kidding don't call
me all the time yeah no
no that was a fun game here's a guy
right here who's got some issues
oh it's me someone actually pointed this
out you guys made a bet
eight over 18 months ago and the bet has
come
let's take a look back uh someone owe
someone money in there
run her on the betty white life i'll go
140 but how long do you think she's
gonna live though
i would like how is she now though i'm
not sure
100 i want two to one odds for the next
18 months
97. back nine bro
one of the funniest women out there
funniest people but also one of the
funniest women she had a style of her
own man that's
you know sometimes you get a lot of a
lot of a lot of comedians just trying to
rip off somebody else's style the reason
why any of them i feel like have success
sometimes is because they find their own
style
she had a style all her own and she
still she still will for
for the next 18 months
and so that's beautiful so we're going
140 dollars i want two to one
steal theo's friend in 140
that 18 months was october 5th she died
she she no she stayed alive you said
you took me over nice you took the over
damn damn
pull up the another bet that i pulled up
a bet that i won
right before that one uh you guys had
talked about dustin poirier which you
all oh you lost that one too
uh so oh
yeah it must have been yeah yeah dustin
just came out with a hot sauce today
though also so if you guys want to
is it called diamond hot sauce i don't
know what it's called but it'll
it's literally the tagline this this
stuff will beat the [ __ ] out of you
oh that's great i like that no i'm
joking that's not it oh damn oh i love
that
steve stevo has a hot sauce and goes
this will make your [ __ ] on fire i'm
like
oh that one's a little dude yeah that
hurts can you put that [ __ ] in his eyes
it's called poirier's hot sauce man of
course it's got some kick and some punch
it says
that's creative he fights soon yeah
right
january connor january boy january you
want to bet on that one too
yeah all right let's go double or
nothing then i think
yeah what was the bet for betty 140 all
right
you would have been 520 had she died i
can't believe it during coveted time
she's
kobe can't be real if it's not killing
that lady oh i know well she might just
be locked down though
she's one of those people that don't
leave the house like my dad i don't
think she's like your dad dude she's
like a successful actress
you know i mean your dad seemed like a
cool guy i've seen some images of him
but yeah how old is she now
98. what is this
shout out 98 dude shout out bone thugs
in harmony what else happened in 98.
what was big in 98 can you google that
right now
top 10 musical hits of 1998. and cat i
want to say thank you for entertaining
us on that game and even just giving us
the opportunity
hypothetically thank you for having me
the man that you do not need
ray of light jay-z hard knocks
backstreet boys everybody
everybody yeah
oh get jiggy with it get jiggy with you
ooh that was a jammy jam get jiggy with
it oh i loved it
you think you were too close my heart
will go on by celine dion
too close what was that what was it like
you're making it hard for me
[Applause]
rubbing your dick on her leg that's what
he's talking about
you actually look like hannah gatsby
heavy on the gatsby too looks like he
had a couple servings of gadsden
[Laughter]
dude you should do some stunt double
work with her yeah maybe
you guys met her i haven't no no
but that was the first time i was ever
introduced to
tim dillon uh when he was talking about
the nanette video
[Music]
he just was confusing it with ali wong
he's like have you seen this nanette
it's this short asian pregnant woman she
takes the piss out of everybody
it's hilarious
and then he went on to talk about domo's
pizza i don't know
he's going to be zooming into a kingdom
sting soon who is tim dylan yeah yeah oh
fun hell yeah i supposed to go over his
house for thanksgiving then he canceled
it
he said there's a covered uproar i'm
gonna pass well
i said you're lost no pecan pie at a hot
pecan pie come
come to his house you're lost brother
that pecan's worth covet to me
yeah i went over to brenda's house for
thanksgiving how was it good
it was good i went last year it was okay
you came out last year
this year was better the food was better
it was great i made the gravy from
scratch yeah because you said other
years you don't get like thanksgiving
food
no my girl [ __ ] [ __ ] burritos and
then the mexican holiday it's lit as
[ __ ] at my house
oh yeah but this thanksgiving we really
went all out what is their
um what is this right here yeah brendan
and also no clue what is this nick this
was uh
cats in the wild someone found footage
of uh i don't know if this was at
thanksgiving but it was brendan vs
chappelle
fighting oh my gosh
oh wow not a lot of power in either one
oh my god oh there it is
underwater
and that that wasn't the only uh cat's
crew members uh battling
um and these are getting very loose by
the way i understand none of them look
like us but this was chin
versus eye freestyling versus me first
oh i see i saw this oh my gosh
man those raps were soft you can never
go hard
the only moaning you hear is when your
mom sees your report cards
i think this is orange county yeah yeah
this is westminster
if you do get a girl is it like frat
party i think yes
with two you can't even get a date
[Music]
kind of nervous and who is that in the
background holding who is this
obviously this kid or something's being
sex trafficked look at that
boy zoom in there uh i think that used
to be my opener
song i'm gonna go back and zoom in on
that
you can't zoom in on the quick time i
can take a screenshot uh can you
yeah let's see what we can do here
because this is alarming that kid is
yeah he don't you know and he's
very small for that yeah it's dangerous
no he lives in apartment five dude
are they in the hallway of a like dorm
it's like i don't know how old kids are
these days
look at that yeah yeah it doesn't look
safe he looks like arthur
yeah it's the artwork that's a
and that meme he was about to punch his
sister yeah yeah
look man you know it's great man she you
know
his sister dw she needs to tighten up
you know what i'm saying man that's the
one that that's when you gotta be to
beat your sister when you're a kid yeah
your kids don't leave acceptance
me and my sister got some fights she
pushed me down the stairs i didn't know
you had a sister yeah she pushed me
oh there's another part in and we're
going to bring her in now every
chapel has some new distant family
member that's the way chappelle gets
meet his family
yeah yeah the king of this thing thank
y'all speaking of chappelle going
downhill
this is probably the most submitted uh
king in the sting or cat's in the wild
ever it's been sent to all of us like
hundreds of times us that fat kid
[Laughter]
how that feels chappelle i would never
do that i land on my feet
damn you heard it here first guys he
redeemed himself
did he yeah he landed another one where
he landed yeah
you know what there's something
beautiful about knowing you're not gonna
land it and just
riding right into it like you are gonna
yeah yeah face first
oh dude it's something special he got
stuck in the air he wasn't flipping
anymore he just
he just stopped and then just you got to
respect that man gravity was like
come here yeah that's like when i did
the american ninja warrior course didn't
we play that on here before
you did it you did it yeah you were
actually on the show
yeah i would know i was on the course
though oh oh wow you decided to jump on
the
the course um yeah are you nimble on
your feet
yeah that course isn't
both feet i don't think i'm nimble i'm
like semi-nimble
oh okay wow that's that horse is a beast
though right it's pretty difficult
is there video i think there is that's
me shaving my legs
how old were you 15 16.
you look young did you shave to get
aerodynamic for that
aerodynamic you got to get ready there
you go you heat up you got to stretch
oh look at this stretch took it
seriously get the cheeks out
very important keep scrolling and that's
me getting ready
and then i think oh you fell in the
water fell in the water
there may be the video though oh little
bruise
took that bruise bro i took that hard
hit i forgot about that that might have
been from something else
but we factored that in yeah is it is
there is there is there video
how then i can have video of you doing i
know go back and scroll down is ninja a
warrior still
is this still going on uh yeah that's
huge
i think american ninja warrior still is
there was a different show that came out
similar to titan's
swipe out i think is another one someone
died on a wipe out
someone died a wipe out yeah the other
day somebody
shattered their neck or something really
yeah
jesus some guy no the japanese guy yeah
i made that up oh the japanese lived
forever but i feel like wipeout would be
the thing to take on now someone did die
and wipe out
yeah oh [ __ ] you're saying you're joking
oh damn that [ __ ] is scorpion
she is flexible but that's not the
person but she's not flexible that's the
scary part
yeah that's also why she died
yeah i don't think it was her that died
um
what were we getting into what else were
we getting into sorry i took us on this
dude how was your thing steven theo
yeah um it was pretty chill
what'd you do in nashville david
arquette invited me over actually
how was that it was fun did you guys
wrestle he's got some children no he
showed me like some memorabilia
he has like memorabilia okay and so we
looked at it
and uh you said on tbw you cried in your
car in the morning i didn't cry my car
in the morning
it's just just seasonal kind of stuff
probably you know
i was trying to get donuts they were
closed
i was already going through some stuff
actually they had one donut left when i
went in there
and you got it huh did you get it uh no
i didn't
i just didn't it was like uh bacon maple
butter yeah yeah that's not the one to
get
no yeah it just wasn't the one that you
know i would cry over that too yeah so
i just love it it's almost like an omen
yeah yeah i was like
you don't need this yeah you don't need
that and i was like what do i need
you know and then the tears started
coming so that's when it hit yeah
but then after that yeah went out there
they live out in the country so it's
kind of nice to be out in the country
is he still married to courtney comics
no he got married he has a different
wife his wife
is named i think christy and how do you
guys know each other
we know each other through just being
alive and just
um you had him on your show he came on
this past weekend yeah
yeah because he has a new uh documentary
out called you cannot kill david
arquette
when he right he he he almost died
wrestling right yeah he almost died and
he lived
or he did both yeah he's still alive i
mean i saw him
wow a renaissance man listen man the
thing
i'm gonna do this season i'm giving
everybody manscape because i'm sick of
my boys
i'm sick of my dad having them big
bushes all the time
there's nothing lamer than when you're
having a little lunch or something with
your daddy and you see his pubis bro
disgusting we in the home gym oh you see
his public hair
like a 70s porno not up in here ho ho ho
fellas
naughty or nice tis the season mustache
oh
dude the ducktale down your backside
what are we talking about man
something let's get a spine sideburn
come right out your spine and go right
down yeah
yeah i got the chops on your ass man
and right now manscape can help you with
their performance package it's the
ultimate men's hygiene bundle
that makes for the perfect gift this
holiday season all that ass
ah imagine opening up an attractive box
that says your balls will thank you
look guys 79 of partners hold admitted
that long nose hair is a major turn off
so why not use the best tools for the
job maybe oh
yes dude get the bundle it includes the
lawnmower 3.0 trimmer
all right yep get that nose straight tis
the season to get your set
uh yourself your dad your brother your
nut gun brother shoot your nuts hairless
how about your hairy aunt
let her know that mustache ain't hip
anymore pop that [ __ ] off get 20
off in free shipping with the code king
sting at manscaped.com
it's a great stocking or it's a great
regular gift get it for a damn child bro
bald is the last out that's 20 off and
free shipping with code
kingstonmanscape.com
20 off with freeshipping and
manscape.com use code king staying go
whack your weeds
i'll tell you what's not cool anymore
when you got streaks in your underwear
listen
don't have any more streaks get that
bidet man
get a bidet right now this holiday
season
uh you gotta get on it with hello tushy
don't get stuck with the post-turkey day
disaster
protect your pipes with the hello tushie
but day
for years bidets have cost thousands of
dollars and only the rich had them
not anymore man thanks to hello tushy
you can get it right get it tight get it
clean
every hello tushy bidet attachment comes
with a 60 day risk free
happy butt guarantee a 12 month warranty
doug yeah
because with hello tushy you don't wipe
at all man hello tushy is your new
hands-free butt
buddy all right but buddy we ain't
talking about when your family reunions
dog
get 10 off plus free shipping right now
at hellotushy.com
k-a-t-s that's hello tushy dot com slash
cats that's hellotushy.com cats for temp
shutoff and free shipping hellotushy.com
cats but here's somebody who's not alive
actually right now
[Laughter]
so i had a debate club which fight did
you guys think was more interesting
jake paul the rest of it was just
ratchet i thought the rest of it we
might as well have
i might as well have that's crazy
we could do that and be more
entertaining
that's a good question because you
thought brian could handle me
or you guys all thought i can brian
trains though yeah i
okay brian knew callan yeah yeah brian
kelly brian would handle you in
heartbeat
even when he's geriatric yeah it's not
even a yeah yeah
what's telling that thing dude yeah it's
not safe no your glasses fog up when you
get too close to that little grill
glasses when i fight though but i'm just
right that's not going to help you i
can't
see it no because my distance is good
it's just when it's super close
they're going to be all it's going to be
like this on my face
i'm shocked that people think that brian
can hang with me i am
well who would win yeah between
chappelle and chin
yeah chappelle's pretty athletic he's
very athletic we can get you guys to
fight maybe he can fight on ellis mania
i know he has different fights every
year
or or if maybe we like start calling out
bar steel people we get chin on rough
and rowdy
we send them send them out east send me
out what is that
send you back east it's just it's it's
just tough man
or we do a cats live and uh at the end
of it you guys [ __ ] fight to the
death
to the death that's a little extreme but
you know we got to keep chin around for
a little while listen i still have to
fight johnny curtis
at least cpr i'm not doing it yes i'm
not fighting until i fight johnny curtis
fight for your job
but i need chappelle to harness your
inner war demon dog
that anger man demon is a racial slur no
it's
not dude thanks to you you're welcome if
you if you can just
if we can bring back some of his anger
then we got to fight
that's true you shouldn't be all nice we
need you know yeah that's because jin
got that in her han
yeah and i do feel like i need to get it
out sometimes so that would be cool
ooh he said i mean i'm not calling out
no you just did
no yeah he just did he said once you
kick flip these nuts in your mouth
oh gosh i can't wait for this press
conference
where they talk [ __ ] to each other yep
well we're doing it so
yeah well i'm not good at talking [ __ ]
so i don't like you as a person
yeah that there we go
here we go yeah no but haven't you guys
done like back i remember when i was
growing up i would always do backyard
like with gloves on boxing gloves we
would just fight yeah sure and we do it
constantly
yeah so it'll be like one of those
things like we we're still friends but
we just go at it
during that little fight are you going
to respond though he said he doesn't
like you as a person
yeah that's what i did i'm not trying to
hear her kill him in the backyard yeah
i do like chapelle though yeah but you
guys gonna fight dude
let's put some odds on it nick what are
the odds once we're in the ring then
then we'll just let it all out but then
wait if chin wins does that count as a
hate crime
huh no because it's not anymore yeah
both
that's why we're minorities with a safe
zone i think i'm going minus
minus 190 chapelle what does that mean
that's a two to one you're the one
yeah oh since nick is doubting me i
would like to
box nick as well who do you guys have on
that who do you guys have on that i mean
ooh
producer producer yes that's my
[Laughter]
perfect yeah nick also has an array she
didn't have a dag
but i would say this chin has raged from
like thousands of years ago
so does nick wisconsin know if nick does
wisconsin
come on i just yeah ming dynasty or
whatever
i mean are we you know what i'm saying
i'm not saying oh yeah he has something
you know he's got that passion
his car nick quit college to gamble for
god's sake
and he finished college no i finished uh
audio engineering school
it sounds like you guys should be in the
car together
it's a perfect fight yeah dude sounds
like they should be a tag team yeah
nick would beat the [ __ ] out of you in a
fight i think honestly and so does nick
thank you that means we have to do it
then
fine with me what's up if nick is down
you know i love you nick i got chin i
will do
gloves it's like you know it's not going
to kill each other yeah whatever makes
you feel good
listen really
no headgear mouthpieces i'll be the rev
what on the headgear no no i hate
headgear you can't see that well
all right okay fine i know
none of these comments are going to come
back to help you i don't think
when's this going down you want to end
of january you guys want you two months
to train
this is [ __ ] hilarious we'll vlog it
would you like to count down with you
too
yeah i'm not doing any of that but i
will be at the fight
or at least watch on facetime no you're
going to be in nick's corner yeah i'm
not being a knicks corner dude
huh it's custom auto well here's the
thing i think we need to pick who's
going to be in the corner i'm not going
to be i'm not a corner man
i'm pulling to mike perry you can have
your girlfriend in your corner
uh her and i'm going to i'm going to
silent auction you can uh dm me how much
you want
darren guarantee how much you got
what's up dog get in there that's
hilarious
so what were the so what the rules be
how many minute rounds i'll tell you
this
is a autographed bottle of pourier's hot
sauce
i'll tell you that right that's a solid
prize i would say i fight for that
three three two minute rounds how is
chappelle fighting anyone now because it
turned into china yeah chapelle's
talking a lot of smack maybe there's a
tough female that chipotle can fight
most people in the youtube comments want
to okay
do they not like baby unique did she get
lit up
huh it was hit it was 50 50. yeah
voice is cracking all right i do think
woah vicky and baby unique would be a
good fight though
so we can put them on the card no we
need
chappelle against a strong hearty female
yes
but who's a strong sanctioned yeah come
on well he doesn't have these things we
need to agree to do it here fortune
feamster
fortune isn't i mean i don't think she's
strong i think she's hearty
i'll grapple with a woman but i'm not
gonna fight a woman look this woman's
gonna beat your ass you're gonna have to
yeah we're gonna find sona really beat
your ass man yeah
she'll be big and aggressive i
could get i could ask that lady gene
brother you need like a lizzo
type of um you want to fight lizzo i
want you to find a big hefty girl who's
really gonna sock it to you
well i want you to fight him put up pull
up lizzo
okay how tall
no lesbo who's a hearty woman that's in
the ufc man come on brendan they're not
going to be you're not really any hardy
they're all small you don't even know
your job dude
you don't kick my ass i'm not oh
lizzie's 5 10.
she's fine i'm 5 11. that's a good fight
[Laughter]
ah it's a solid matchmaking fight that's
what we call on the business a coin flip
yeah odds are even
could you beat liza i i think you could
probably beat it uh i don't know
she got shot in the foot though didn't
she no no
when i thought of tough women i thought
jillian michaels she's she's not
she's not gonna do it she's a little too
famous all right all right
but lizzo isn't okay
grammy nominated listen we can barely
get woe vicky
we got baby unique okay who's a
part-time stripper from a reptile
convention
okay let's be honest what's going on
i don't know she was great it was going
downhill she was great brother who the
[ __ ]
she was like i'm a dj the snake that's
the crazy part
still there chilling she ate my dog
she's like i think he's tired
of the box colin took it home really
yeah wow
so i don't know who chappelle could find
this place has turned into a halfway
house for a complete
i thought i was fighting johnny curtis
no johnny would beat the [ __ ] out of him
we need to work on somebody else cat
versus riley mao
ooh i think i could take
i feel like i can take him oh yeah i
think he could how about how about
chappelle and uh
jelly roll no she has so much love
yeah oh i don't know yeah no jelly
roll's not going to live that long dude
and no offense jelly roll but also what
do i know dude i lost 140
on betty white yeah yeah don't take it
from me jelly roll i would talk to your
doctor
you know who'd be great for chappelle i
just thought of it derrick
okay ooh derek post oh dude that's too
blemish
that is blemish you can't you gotta yeah
i think you just can't do that
you don't wanna fight derek it's just
two ah that's
afterwards it's done everything's cool i
think my friends was like square it was
like detroit square dancing i felt like
yeah that [ __ ] was
weird yeah oh god
um oh wait there's raleigh matt right
now what is he saying
what happened
okay but we need to fight and i think it
should be a strong woman
are we doing in the in like do we want
to bring it back like kimbo style and
doing like a backyard
or do we want an actual ring i don't
think we're getting a ring man
oh we could do that box and burn we
could do it in the living room here
right here just move the table yeah
move the table bro that's the last word
of somebody that dies
we'll do it right here just move the
table that nick nick was born fighting
like that you sure you want to do that
chin you see us
yeah we'll do it here yeah that's right
you grew up yeah just move the aquarium
yeah yeah we're gonna introduce words to
somebody that drowns dude
this is basically nick's home you're
going to give him home advantage yeah
100 percent
dude whatever aquarium that's like going
full circle you're an asian person yeah
that's what you get dude you got to
think about that when you if an asian
person
when they go to the ocean that's like
going to mcdonald's for them you know
it is we're very out one with the water
yeah and fish
yes exactly they're like oh i'm just
going to swim in this mcdonald's
mm-hmm think about that man y'all don't
[ __ ] think enough bro
you can't even think of a woman a fight
dude what kind of [ __ ] man
what kind of black guy are you
i can't find a woman yes you can bro you
got a channel
you got to channel your grandparents
bro when women used to get a you know
and i'm not saying it's good or anything
but women used to get hit by men oh look
at that look at riley mao
and some of you oh they look identical
what about aaron brockovich
aaron brockovich who's that aaron brock
best movie ever with julia roberts she's
a lawyer
what about legally blonde we're we're
doing female lawyers
dude what's your name you're avoiding
this
brook ants are you gays going to fight
or not dude
they're fighting would be good brook
ants would be good look her up next are
they the main event nick's screaming
that's the main event not fighting
boxing and chin's not helping either
chin keeps
like oh we'll move the uh chin's like
let's move the table out there move
around
let's fight in the kitchen we'll move
the fridge
it doesn't have to be pretty the [ __ ]
fight yeah it's a fight oh my god
chappelle i think yeah would be a good
match who's that brook
ends she was in wonder woman she's one
of the amazonians
what was she an american gladiator the
remake that didn't uh really take off
for something was like called tag or
something over that show
what did you want me to meet her i think
she was also in the balco labs as well
how tall is she i don't know how tall
she is
you care about height way too much she's
pretty hot though does it not have to do
with that very pretty
very pretty yeah she's really does i
have anything to do with it when you're
fighting
i don't know i mean listen are you guys
level just get in there you just get in
there got it
oh she's yeah she's she'd beat me and
theo up
i i would i think i could go to at least
two rounds with it
i'd go six rounds with her bro are we
still talking about fighting god look at
this yeah
yeah if we're not i go a half round
if not i'm not last in the main event
with her thing how about you guys
guys uh send in people who you think
would be a good opponent for chappelle
you know chapelle are you willing to
take on an opponent that's a big
question i thought i'm fighting brooke
if she i think she's gonna pass what
about brooke hogan she has a real
problem i think she's always gonna pass
we're kind of shooting for the moon what
about brook hogan
is good i don't think brook's gonna be
down guys
yeah i don't know if she's in the vlog
brooke you want to fight our [ __ ] big
friendship
aunt brooke i know brook came out to a
show of mine in atlanta actually her
fiance white guy i just want to give you
guys an update on that poll
69 of people said that chappelle would
win in a fight against chen
wow no respect that's like the exact
same as minus 190 implied odds yeah
you're right
i'll put put up nick and chin too nick
and chen okay
and and and let's send in some
suggestions but are you willing to fight
your fault i don't want you to feel like
you have to we're people i don't know
this isn't a [ __ ] fight okay listen what
kind of fight am i doing you're doing
boxing
boxing it's just fighting bro you're
fighting somebody i already said
yesterday you know how much you would
have to pay me to fight someone
well we're going to pay you i know he's
exactly how much we're going to pay
we're probably going to pay you 450
and you get a back end of the
pay-per-view yeah
[Laughter]
for 450 i mean look you could put it
live you could probably put it live and
if you wanted to buy a ticket to it but
a good idea
gosh that's the move what about like the
grappling stuff you know
i don't want to no don't punch anyone we
could no we could make it it could be
muay thai it could be um i'll tell you
i don't know what uh chevelle dude help
us out here you're not helping you know
everything about fighting you're not
even helping dude i
i want nick and chin to fight in and we
need a fine opponent for chappelle
the fans don't want to see you do
grappling because you don't do jiu jitsu
so
we need to boxing everybody gets yeah we
don't want to see two [ __ ]
fat people laying there hugging each
other okay people i'm not talking about
you i'm talking about two other people
that would just be in the ring
that would jump in but i'm just saying
we need yeah we need we need some hype
you can also toss on something you want
to do a four-fight card
no you don't have to be a female that's
where it's dicey that's what you said
yes i do it it would make a heart bro
you're an [ __ ] this is a woman that
will is going to want to beat your ass
now yeah i'm kind of
into it too yeah now i'm back on track
bro it's not
we're talking about a big [ __ ] dude
that's really chopping up
baby we're not talking spousal beats
we're not talking about eight turner
type [ __ ] you know drowning your wife in
the bathtub
no we're talking about cyborg we're
talking about cyborg like in her head
okay we're talking about something with
the bell rings dude this woman gonna
come over here
see how you do it how you doing kyla
harrison
what about the girl from what about
paige van zandt
that's a tough one pro you know and very
pretty i think she's
trying to knock me out kyle harrison
kyla harrison would beat all of us up
yeah but you get ct you're more likely
to probably work on the show for a
longer time
i'm just going to be if we call you the
freaking dark brendan
you get you get a longer leash i make a
lot of mistakes chappelle but i just
chalk it up
ct would uh cat fight rudy from bad
friends
oh with that sort i feel like she's a
boyfriend she's from the philippines
yeah
asians from the philippines from like
third world countries
have a little more scrap in them than
like asian born asians yeah we're
talking about i feel like she might have
me
she's out there yeah i've never seen her
she's cool
she's fresh out the trees calm down
brendan i'm just saying she's 18 years
old
is she really yeah she's 16 she has her
first boyfriend
is that true cat like 17 i think
somebody said bobby's kid from like a
marriage or something did you hear that
i have no idea his niece from the
philippines yeah sure that's something
i'm gonna believe theo yeah i don't know
it's like a great cover up for uh
a kid that brought us my niece that
you've never heard of yeah right
from the philippines but now i will say
this man a lot of
asian people will you bring one family
member in next thing you know you get
out the car with them and they got
another fan like who's this who's your
car watch the countdown
yeah watch all up in the video
everyone has a buddy i told gianni he
should fight jake paul
next but uh he's like i make real money
i'm not gonna do it for a hundred
thousand dollars that was johnny said
that yeah yeah wow
i bet i bet jake paul made as much as he
makes on the season of power
what 100 no i bet jake paul got paid so
they had some back end of the ticket
sales or something
they made some money you guys still what
was the money how much money did they
make on that they made 600k
uh uh jake paul made 600k than a backend
of pay-per-views
so everybody gets around two million
three million how many pay-per-views did
they sell do you know there were so many
different reports
they saved sixty dollars six hundred
sixty thousand and then six hundred
thousand
it's six hundo he ain't fighting for
sixty thousand dollars no no
his name alone on there is worth a
million is worth a million yeah
did you watch it there i did watch it
man i felt like i and i tweeted about
this i felt like i was stuck in a
nightclub in jacksonville in in uh 2004.
it was just like a lot of smoke a lot of
reaction and a lot of uh
i thought it was interesting how the
boxing looked like a video game a little
bit when you looked at it because it was
all white and black
black just like yeah this reminded me of
like a video game where you could just
see what was going on just specifically
i thought it was entertaining i paid
another 50 for it but
how long were you in particular that was
a real fight breaks a sales record right
there number five
four mike tyson versus no that that
that's
but dana does the same things as
promoters going this trend to be the
biggest pay-per-view
ever like that's not real uh that's not
real that that's the promoter who owns
it going
we're on track to be the biggest
pay-per-view ever and everyone's like oh
my god we gotta get it like it's
just honeydew was there anything in like
black culture where people were like
excited about this did you hear anything
from like what for this fight yeah
uh no i wasn't paying attention he's not
he's not heroes are these considered
heroes in the black community
oh roy jones and tyson yeah yeah like
breakfast club was all over it like i
listen to them every morning and they
were hyping this thing up
but at least charlemagne was real like a
lot of people especially in my world
were like oh that was dope i'm like get
the [ __ ] out of here man
then finally like charlemagne shannon
sharp like dude i don't know what the
[ __ ] people are watching like that was a
[ __ ] show
it's just people saying what they think
their bosses want them to say to you
agree keep the money oh really and i
also think people have so much respect
for mike tyson where they don't want to
call it what it is
where it's just like it's a money play
it was like a buddy
it was like a gentleman's agreement
that's right it was not fun watching
them hug
for 16 minutes it wasn't fun i get that
roy was probably hugging for safety i
mean if
some of those blows if he caught him
with him it could have been pretty bad
did you see the fights
then agreement he wouldn't hit him to
the face like that so also it's like
hang in there you know yeah it's almost
like um
and they called it a draw right yeah
yeah would you did you feel like it was
a draw
tyson definitely won it listen
it was it was a gentleman's bet where
tyson's gonna win that's why you're
never gonna get tyson holyfield
because holyfield ain't gonna play that
game holyfield beat him twice in real
combat so if you go to holyfield go hey
dude we'll give you five million but you
gotta
you gotta let me beat you he's like get
the [ __ ] out tyson was on that mustard
too i felt like they had him j i mean he
was like yolk
jacks yeah he lost a hundred pounds
damn ooh they i i if i'm his
trainers or whatever i have him ju i
have him juiced up
i have already i don't know why roy roy
wasn't that i don't know why he didn't
get juicy
roy showed up definitely like he'd been
roy had that stuff
yeah for reals that's jews i think it
has to be and no offense to him that's
what i would do
it's trt 100 53 to get lean like that
and muscle
of course well i did juice to be in the
11th grade so i respected him
did it prepare you for 11th grade uh i
remember walking through
the don't get bullied pretty
hey chin are you going to juice for the
fight against nicki thank you juice trt
nick will get on yourself you're already
on that crazy i have an
update with that what do you say
i love big tattoos
so 67 of fans said that they think chin
would be
nick in a fight and people would like to
see rosie o'donnell versus chappelle
put it up on the cat's eye rosie will
you fight chappelle okay what about
roseanne
no no you know let me say something
roseanne she keeps saying hey will you
uh she keeps commenting on pictures and
saying what did she say
dm me i've dm'd her five times
that's a power move theo well it's
getting powerless
[Laughter]
it's just played out at this point it's
crazy
that bumped me out i was really excited
when i saw that first guy
i every time she sends one i'm like
hello
nothing no does show that it's red uh
maybe she doesn't know how to work her
dm but then how why would you say dm me
i don't maybe her assistant she's saying
that and her assistant supposed to check
him and doesn't
maybe just shoot her attacks get her
number from rogan
maybe shoot my nuts onto your back son
i'm sorry
so rosie o'donnell okay do you guys
we're gonna ask that why can't my boy
should probably get a real opponent man
we asked him 70 times he will offer up
no one
okay what was the percentage of uh
people that picked chin
uh 67 so far he looks a lot bigger than
me because this gopro
[Laughter]
do you guys see david chang he became
the first celebrity ever to attempt the
gas at a million
i don't know if you guys know what
happened is this a spoiler
and where is he from is he from uh wait
hold on i know he's a chef
is he the guy on rogan no no no no no
who am i who am i thinking of jin
uh eddie wong i like him yeah he's eddie
wong
he's
yeah i think that was it all right mina
although he and his wife never touched a
light switch for fear of being shocked
who was the first president to have
electricity in the white house
you listen to that ulysses s grant
benjamin harrison
chester a arthur or andrew johnson
should we call someone should we phone a
friend anybody in your phone and see if
they know this
uh i'll go d i would call my brother
hey jay can you hear us hello hey jay
can you hear us
hey yeah i can hear you uh you are on
who wants to be a million
who wants to be a millionaire what up
jay
what up theo and brendan are both going
for a million dollars they're on the
final question
and uh they want to know
uh although he and his wife never
touched a light switch for fear of being
shocked who is the first president to
have electricity
in the white house ulysses s grant
b benjamin harrison c chester arthur
or d andrew johnson
it's benjamin harrison hundred percent
oh
wow then benjamin harris i go he sounds
pretty confident
yeah i'll go with b benjamin harrison
there you go confidence
bravado went out i'm gonna go
final answer b
benjamin harrison fine god i wish i was
[Music]
just want you a million dollars wow jay
you got it
you got it yes did jay see that clip
probably dude it was threatening on
twitter i didn't jay's the guy that
called
with all those weird facts you've been
on the road with jake yeah he's just on
some nice random [ __ ] yeah like we'll go
buy a building like you know in 1774
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] everybody was
talking to us about octopus
he just had all this knowledge on
octopus i love how brendan gets a fact
presented in his first thought is i
don't
care well it's not it's relentless dude
it sounds like one fact right no it's
not it's all non-stop isn't it chappelle
when i first met jay i think like his
opening line to me was he was explaining
to me why vietnamese people like
hennessy
you did not say you're kind how about
when i was like man i don't i don't want
to eat octopus anymore i think they're
really dope and they're smart i want to
eat him he goes
well you could order because you know
their average lifespan is three to five
years
all right dude give us a whole whole
information on it dang it's beautiful
man it sounds like a beautiful shirt
what about versus jay shaw oh
damn i feel like jay would get it oh
that would be a bad idea
yeah who would win jake and fight jay's
better fighter than i am
really oh yeah see yeah he's already got
real anger issues
and i also think he's juicing so yeah i
would agree with that probably
he just laughs let's get into the
episode what else do we have nick
i d i do need uh jay to be my witness uh
if the lakers don't win the nba
championship
next year malik owes me three thousand
dollars oh yeah that's right oh wow
yeah that's actually not a bad bet
that's not a bad it's it's plus 350
right yeah and you guys shook on it wow
three grand malcony's get off the lakers
nut
that's the episode nick well thanks jay
you just won uh your
a millionaire you want me a diet coke
jay thanks excellent
oh thanks all right dude
thanks jay uh new cats merch drops
friday
10 a.m with the
dot sauce k-a-t-s merch.com that's
awesome man 10 a.m doggy
a lot of new goodies christmas goodies
holiday goodies oh
get your side piece a dope ass hoodie
um chappelle is it okay if we let uh
listeners uh see
who rosie who wants to fight you i
thought it was rosie
i don't think she she may want to teach
again i i like where you guys head out
and i i encourage everybody's and i
evaluate league of their own she's yeah
she's
she's a great movie yeah she's a great
movie yeah she's a good
too famous yeah let's let's keep
shooting though you know yeah
let's keep our options open yep probably
dude
is there another comedian um
he doesn't want to fight oh you don't
want to fight at all no
well i asked you 20 times man yeah we
have kind of i thought
we were going to i thought you guys were
going to put a million up for me to
fight uh
yeah no we said 450. we at 450.
american dollars though 450 american 450
yen
maybe we put yeah i mean we could put
like a thousand on it i'll give you a
million yen how about that no give me
you guys a zoo in mexico
that thing burns well yeah i mean you
can have it you know but you're taking
on all the liabilities because we're in
a lawsuit right now with the ostriches
it's mostly a graveyard
it's a pet cemetery at this point like
every small business
yeah you can have it dude yeah it's got
belly up
um but nick and chen you guys are
fighting yeah
let's pick a date what's up dog let's
get on the books
well it there has to be another fight on
the card though oh we'll get some other
we have some fans on there
yeah maybe some fans i would watch cat
versus riley marrow though maybe
yeah cat would beat the [ __ ] out of him
we need more competitive [ __ ] dude
i have had offered zero ideas the entire
time
my idea was nick and chin was it nick
i feel like it writes itself to be
honest yeah yeah
nick doubted me to beat chappelle so
then i said oh yeah yeah
oh that was jin's idea it's always hard
getting in a fight with chin all you
have to do is say you think you'd win in
a fight
automatically if i said i could be chin
in a fight he'd be like all right
i would not can't i wouldn't but would i
be angry i would be enough
in vietnamese culture is it okay do more
women get abused you think in
relationships
i feel like more men get abused
vietnamese women are very very head
strong
we're very sweet to other people but
like when the door is closed we will
square up
wow they're strong enemies women are
strong
chin and nick have vietnamese
girlfriends ask them hey we do yeah
your girlfriend versus his girlfriend
what no jin's girlfriend
oh that's too much for you that's where
you draw the line
jules would [ __ ] her up
i don't wanna i don't wanna say anything
bad but
he's probably right well my girlfriend's
petite
and his girlfriend's tall yeah exactly
so cause jules is a stallion she's
like five nine five ten she took she
took some uh
some training before she can she can put
a uh uh rear naked choke on me
then we need we just need someone else
on the damn car i mean maybe
we'll think of someone but the main
event is chin versus nick
and we'll fill up the rest of the car
we'll fill it up okay
we have some time but january end of
january
preach would be the [ __ ] out of
everybody in here probably
probably everybody maybe everybody
brendan
oh yeah preacher lawson mm-hmm yeah he
wants something
he's not even a real preacher though you
know that he's a comedian yeah
so right there who knows what he can
really do
so we'll figure it out i think i think i
think i think preacher versus
a good fight what oh yeah we can have
malik on the card too boxes
because malik used to fight but yeah i
think
it's tough because you just need
somebody who's
who's an equal yeah malk has experience
in boxing that's not funny but he
doesn't have the letter we want a [ __ ]
show
ari mantis versus tony hinchcliffe tony
wouldn't do it but
i like the matchup it'd be a good fight
ari vs chappelle might even be good
i'll fight ari chapelle spell beat the
[ __ ] out of him
see if he wants to smoke yeah
we're the obviously look i want to tell
you right now yeah you can tell how bad
this show is getting because
look where we started off with the where
yeah we're at the point now we're
all calling ari to fight come
hey what's going on man uh are you cool
with being that king in the sting
oh thank you for asking i'm cool with it
what's up ari what's up
um what number episode is this 98. yeah
sorry it took us a while to get to you
but
we have a question brother so um a lot
of you guys know ari mantis
uh opens with me on the road as a
stand-up comedian um
and we uh uh his book is my son's
favorite book by the way ari
oh thanks man that's awesome there's
some spelling errors in there but
whatever
we figure it out
have a couple of fights that are going
down somehow soon he here at ground
and we want to know if do you think you
could fight chappelle lacy in a fight
yeah you have two months to train for it
listen i think
it would be a bad look if i beat up a
black guy that's the only thing
that's a good point but let's say you
don't have to worry about any of that do
you think you could do it
yeah oh i mean
i it would be too easy i would easily
kick
that we got ourselves out of the
contract's in the mail you little hoe
that's what i said but i will agree with
ari there was something about when nate
got hit you're like oh [ __ ] is this
going to be
you know a racial thing when nate got
hit when nate robinson got hit there was
a little bit of that help no
no he did no there's no racism and
there's no racism in fighting there's
none
there's zero that's probably it's just
fine no if it's a sanctioned fight
there's no racism but if i'm just coming
into the king in the sting studio and
just beating him up in your
on your set i feel like i'll get in
trouble
we also got a korean versus a white guy
so i think you're gonna be all right
yeah you're all right yeah i'm gonna
[ __ ] chin up ari
yeah you break the thing
the fear that's bubbling
[Laughter]
can we make sure i can't get enough hell
yeah we're making
fight [ __ ] for this a fight poster i
told look i said straight up ari could
easily handle uh chappelle i thought
you're out of your goddamn wait ari how
tall are you why so
i'm five foot nine and you're five ten
eight five eleven
okay this is perfect but ari's there's
something wrong with aria
he did longboard from san francisco to
[ __ ] l.a
yeah ari's been dead like two or three
times
all right ari we'll get your [ __ ]
mouth piece end of january
i tell you guys what you know chappelle
you're you're a friend of mine i would i
would call you a friend
but uh anything for fame dude i'm
kicking your ass
[Laughter]
okay we'll figure out uh how it's going
to work man and no contract in the mail
me and ari are going skiing we're going
skiing in tahoe on thursday
oh i mean there's probably going to be
like a lot of chicks there
i doubt that playboy have fun though
you're gonna have a great time are you
bringing chicks right already
i'm bringing my homosexual younger
brother so if he counts
well we'll see how cold it is up there
should be real
cockness on that mountain brokeback
mountain over there
all right ariella i'll talk to you later
man thanks for uh thanks for jumping on
the livestream
god bless you guys thanks for having me
on thank you we'll be in touch
wow wow we got ourselves a fist of cuff
we got a fight card we got fourier's hot
sauce that's the prize
i need someone in my corner we'll get
cash prize too now i might get in your
corner if you're going against ari
okay thank you what thank you cause
that's how i am i'll like invite you
over and then i'll freaking coach the
dog that's that
yeah that you don't even think is gonna
be in the room i don't know if i trust
that chappelle
it'd be like one of those mid-fight he
switches smashes a chair over you i
don't trust that
i'll help i'll help you get ready
chappelle you can
oh yeah i think i got it i have some
office i thought i had some more fists
look at that
[Laughter]
and that's the name of the episode right
there i'll save you guys the time small
fists
all right i love you guys game on
brendan and theo fighter and weight i
got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso and the
quesoritos but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in a club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]